في المانيا نظمت اتحاد نقابات العمال
الالمانيه العديد من الاحتجاجات
والفعاليات في عدد من المدن لمناسبه يوم
العمال هذه الاحتجاجات تاتي وفق النقابات
الالمانيه تزامنا مع ازمات الطاقه والبيئه
وحرب اوكرانيا فضلا عن تداعيات جائحه
كورونا وهو ما اثار قلقا في اوساط الطبقه
العامله وفق تعبير المركزيات
معنى من برلين مراسله الجزيره ايمن الزبير
ايمن كيف مرت او كيف تمر كما نشاهد خلفك
هذه التظاهرات والاحتجاجات في برلين
حسن الاحتجاجات مستمره هذا هذه المسيره هي
المسيره التي ينظمها اقصى اليسار وكما
تشاهدون الشعار على الشعار مكتوب خبز سلام
واشتراكيه هذه الاحزاب وهذه المنظمات ترى
انها تدهور الاوضاع المعيشيه للمواطنين
الالماني يعود الى عده اسباب ربما اهمها
سياسات التقشف كما قالوا التي نهجتها
الحكومه الالمانيه ولكنهم يقولون ان هناك
موارد وهذا ما اثبتته السياسات التي طبقت
بعد جائحه كورونا لكن يرون ايضا ان هذه
الموارد يتم صرفها فقط لخدمه مصالح
الحكومه وهنا اشاره الى الدعم الذي تقدمه
المانيا
للقوات الاوكرانيه هذا الدعم العسكري
تراجع اوضاعهم المعيشيه على حد قولهم هناك
تخوف كبير من وقوع اعمال عنف لان هذه
التظاهره في السنوات الاخيره دائما تنتهي
بمواجهات بين المتظاهرين والشرطه
الالمانيه اليوم السلطات هنا في برلين
قالت انها نشرت ازيد من 6000 من عناصر
الشرطه لتفادي وقوع مواجهات ما شاهدناه
اليوم في برلين كان اجواء احتفاليه لم
تخلو من النضال ومن مجموعه من المطالب
اهمها رفع المرتبات امام ارتفاع مستويات
التضخم هؤلاء يقولون انه لم يعد ممكنا
تاجير بيت في برلين وان هناك العديد من
القطاعات الحيويه مثل التعليم في المانيا
التي تضررت وبالتالي يتوعدون الحكومه بصيف
ساخن يقولون ان هذا لن او ان هذه لن تكون
الاحتجاجات الاخيره حسنا اننا الزبير من
برلين شكرا جزيلا